[Music]
citizens of the reject nation is time
for Monarch episode 5 today John how are
you I am excited minus one ladies and
Gentlemen please Roar at that like
button smash that subscribe button thank
you to prepper for editing down these
highlights thank you to all who have
follow us on our patreon page that's
where you catch the full l through watch
SN with your own copy of Monarch we
cover several things exclusively with
highlights and watch Longs included
let's see how EXC exciting and awesome
this episode
is you think you can intimidate me with
all this secret Black Ops no I
survived g
day Great Sound designs whoa whoa whoa
who was in the
[Music]
gurnie is that his dad
watching ah she looks well rested
feeling better I feel great still count
the 10 on my toes you're very lucky We
rescued you when we did Monarch heels
can you wiggle your big toe I assume you
were folding the data on our stolen
files you couldn't recover anything hey
you're not as good as You' think but a
smart girl like you would have a backup
now in The
Ether traditionally when someone
discovers a new species they get to name
it they get to name it for themselves
but we have dilemma here should we call
it Mau titanus May hu
it or lra mat of Tacoma Washington oh
backstory it's that one that
picture doesn't really look like you or
you mcloven the 25-year-old Hawaiian
organ donor who are you really it's not
crazy do you think we could help each
other maybe even like I said it's love
each other always good to D amen oh
they're finally going be answering the
show's biggest questions who is stoic
girl eggshell white the Randa children
know nothing they are hosi randa's kids
they are Bill and KO randa's grandkids
we're treating them like they're
criminals they are Legacy characters
she's a school teacher okay no record
the son is an artist H Everyone's a
Critic this one is interesting from the
way she swept to her apartment she knows
her to disappear why what is she hiding
from She's xcia this organization is in
their blood we we can teach them who
they are monarch is their legacy Legacy
hasn't served people well around here
has it it's a legacy of monsters so the
monsters is the monarch the people the
monsters are the people monstar so let's
say we put them on a Long Leash see
where they lead us Long Leash in a choke
chain what about him he's my problem
now you bet your ass he is why you guys
go ahead and come on out um please do
watch your Stu though it's
slippery they want them to become
Monarch agents yeah that's interesting
turn of events plane tickets money
phones courtesy of Monarch I'm very
sorry about all of this Frick he
just wants them to like him you think
that you're on some uh righteous Crusade
to uncover the
truth yeah wake up oh I've already used
what little influence I have to cover
your asses this time don't expect it to
happen again that was just part of his
plan wasn't it how was that yep you're
learning get them interested yeah
hooking them in be less suspicious if we
knew where Kurt Russell was he's fine
he's chowing down on a steak right now
and solitary sorry for your loss like
they care clearly not basically
economy they would have Flo us first
class you're leaving yeah you heard the
man we have lives to get back to in
Tokyo the one you said I destroyed I
have to do stuff stop it is there a bar
anywhere somewhere it's not open yet one
star no ma'am please I'll make you a
cocktail what about Colonel sha what
about him he knew our father was still
alive no and neither do you but we don't
know that he's dead either I'm not
stopping I need to know what happened to
him him we all need him Monarch may know
how to find the Titans but they don't
know how to find dad he's the real Titan
I already searched his office not the
one in San Francisco backup family
backup office let's go yall can have the
files but they could get you killed or
you we can't split up we need you we're
a family
now oh that's cool why are you showing
me this you want to bet she's still
alive I bet she's still alive she's
probably still alive as unpredictable as
this show has
been now they're going to surprise us
with this
one oh cool wow we they did it deep fake
technology the random boy had that film
on them I've never seen it we stand on
the shoulders of giants you have no idea
Oasis album weighing them down doing
what Monarch does best and what's that
Colonel
nothing monarch Legacy of nothingi
rand's kids that's doing something those
kids have already survived more
situations than half the people you got
working in your field out there and
we've only been doing that for a day you
ever think Hoshi had a reason for not
telling his kids what he did here maybe
he didn't want this life for them I have
thought about that actually you guys are
so mysterious I'll ask him when I see
him yeah reunion I'm assuming you don't
mean in the afterlife no you're not
going anywhere and you're not getting
anywhere anywhere are
you you need me well played you say he
helped found Monarch but that was in the
50s 40s actually so he should be what 90
at least how does he look like that
there's rumors of a mission gone bad
that's what hosi works on how did he go
straight from an old Fox home to finding
a Titan no one in the entire
organization knew existed what does he
know and don't tell me so in the files
oh he's got like Titan blood in him yeah
he's the little clone girl from Jurassic
world I'm going to get really carried
away with my
theories g day dang still got to
rebuild
Oakland Ryan cougler joint now you good
not how I thought I'd make my first trip
to the states what feeling lost and sure
of what you're looking for what you're
going to find his voice sounds so
American I know his accent is Flawless
who is this it's James
Kate hi James what are you doing here
James I told Mom we'd be fine we're not
fine I'm James carolin's work friend
pleasure to meet you may Ando welcome
Hey welcome uh oh my god dude that was
courteous yeah of course of course my
bad is it true they're selling tours of
the destroyed City they did yeah too
many people get irradiated for the
military wed off trauma tourists getting
off on the disaster porn or trying to
prove it was all the government
conspiracy yes oh my God trauma tors
that's a thing that's cool tell your mom
I'll see her
tonight welcome back I think he's dating
her I think they're banging yeah mom's
new sugar Cub wow Kate you're back oh
boy you're
back a you got a lot to live up to Mom
Mom this is May and
kintaro I'm Caroline
hi pleasure nice to meet you I feel like
she recognized that name she knows both
come from Tokyo yeah which part because
my husband used to travel Mom this is
karanda oh just RI that Band-Aid off you
ask what I found in
Tokyo my God reversal it's the opening
credits James is my work friend we
collect people's personal items James
and his giant peach man they know how to
cat ask the mom's I know the heart of
the show you never ask for money or
valuables you always seem to be asking
for these things they personal memories
a oh wait let me help you I got I don't
need your help with anything
stop I got
it you looks so much like him inviting
him in to get settle like your husband's
secret son walks in every day what do
you expect me to do throw M have a
hysterical breakdown go for it I
wouldn't blame you anyone on this show
have a hysterical breakdown no man
Legacy of
repressed your father was never really
all here find out if he was having an
affair or had a girlriend so you sent me
there uh and you pushed because you
wanted the truth but you were too
chicken sh to go yourself wow yeah don't
talk to me like that I only wanted what
was best for you and this was it I mean
yes yes what was I supposed to do you
spent all day tell her
go find out if your dad had an affair go
to all the way to Japan you couldn't
even lift a finger to help yourself it
was my choice and I wasn't going to sit
around and watch my daughter herself oh
we're going to Dad's office we don't
even know if there's anything left of
his office well you can get us into the
city to find out no not into the Red
Zone the military has a cordoned off
they're arresting looters every day some
of them even get shot let's go it's a
weird Choice mom weird Choice gotta
say that's what I would do seems like
the most logical scenario to get to the
answers quickly he's got Godzilla trauma
to deal with Dad dead trauma take a trip
go to Japan and find out if he's having
an affair where's kby tonight kids got
the flu again oh damn she got some
secrets too he's got Godzilla flu he's
got Kai flu for your
troubles we don't want to hold your
lineup oh my God I guess it is just a
work friend theyd be
bribing
get these folks moving we good to
go Roger
that such tension hope you get a the
after Cara you deserve it thanks good to
go history good hint at history there
appreciate that they gave that character
her name I love that character and her
name cool you can see the bridge through
the fog yeah it's ear very terrifying
reminder how can anyone believe this is
fake oh you'd be surprised the guards
make sure that everybody we bring in
comes out with us they'll assume your
looters no questions no excuses and we
need to leave by morning we'll be here
at 800 at 8:15 they close the gates damn
15 minutes going to be enough you're
going to get into some kind of Chase
Stakes are
high have to get some answers
oh no there is something intimate going
on this the show is just about Affairs
and intimacy yeah repressed people who
don't know how to communicate it's like
closer it's called Closer yeah it's
called closer one with jul law Natalie
pman and Julie Roberts and Clive Owen
that closer yeah you went decades
between Escape attempts why start
raising hell again now you're supposed
to be 90 yes smartest people on the
planet have had 60 years to prepare for
gday Let them fight that's the best they
could come up with Let Them Fight I see
in the room and S there W what's hiding
in b randa's files nothing you don't
already know you think you had it rough
playing shuffle board and trimming your
bun ey tree I never said I had a rough I
got I swear to God I can bury you deep 6
foot deep Monarch is wrong you're lying
has been for a long
long
time oh the theme music all this
dialogue has been tell me what I want to
know about mysterious thing oh you don't
even realize how mysterious mysterious
things are yeah you you don't even know
yeah yeah you don't even know what don't
I know we don't owe you information the
no the
no I know we don't have the information
either and then it goes equals m
serious even if a building looks
undamaged the attack undermined the
foundation so sometimes you'll hear one
just suddenly collapse it makes a lot of
sense playing enough video game to S the
same thing he snacking back here might
as well probably boring after a certain
point I do love those Godzilla sets from
the other movie yes it's really giving
me fond memory of watching that film was
this your
neighborhood yeah that was our favorite
little coffee shop
Starbucks oh my God hero I like
it oh oh my God this show just got a lot
better woke
Zilla oh my God yes oh yes character
development more of that I needed that I
needed that that too dude the Barista
and the guy back there are also having a
great
exchange oh and it's right under the
pride flag I guess it is San
Francisco of course it's the first of
the month more games hey everyone in San
Francisco is gay everyone's it's cheaper
to live with two rather than one
a you don't have to choose between your
Ethiopian dark roaster food every day
I'll be your sugar mama haven't you
learned learned your lesson haven't you
yeah question M mystery the what mystery
you don't
know we can't hide our
pride dude I bet Godzilla like
incinerated her
personally oh my God so it begins So It
Begins you mean the beginning of the end
when two women kiss it's hot when two
guys kiss I cry and then they went to
their sixth grade math
classus one they had to know they
changed the credits yeah I bet they
probably maybe did their parents are
scared of the giant monsters mine aren't
my dad said it's a hoax to burst the
real estate
balloon definitely he's
right all right phone's away this has to
be a prank of some kind a freaking weird
spare their feelings everyone okay here
we're fine today's lesson don't believe
everything you see on the internet we're
monitoring the situation closely make
sure their phones are charged and they
all know their family reunification
plans wowe yeah we decide to close the
school but educate them yes teach them
I'm sure they can focus go on with your
lessons plan
yeah I Like These Quiet Place flashbacks
the first quiet play quiet place minus
one who's there come out where we can
see you minus one equals Ground
Zero
what psychic power Last of Us where's
this one heading north for the Golden
Gate come on come on gay day gay day
there's got to be some kind of
correlation they're only letting buses
across the bridges okay are you sh
Runing this one I can take it if you
want to stay with
Danny that's right she was on a school
bus you think she's alive
love I'm going to I'm this is exciting I
would have gladly have seen an epic show
that just took place in this this
is great the suspense of these
flashbacks feels really the last of
us got this they like chips yeah they
won't be able to
resist is that a chip on the
ground get back
chips oh divide these up
[Music]
evenly you got
movement Titans a the original Titans
just more damn cats I think we should
start shooting them there's so many cats
in the quarantine Zone there's got to be
a correlation Legacy of
kittens look how cool these shots are
though man pretty sick good set design
good debris
move get out the way look at him he's an
older brother cheering up his sister
John you're not taking any of this
seriously now pretending to take it
seriously a that was a sweet you're
trying too hard John dad would sing
these
cheesy oh but it's it relates to their
dad so it's plot
development I'm glad they they feel
comfortable to sing loudly after after
cing soldiers oh my God yeah there's
Doll cats over there you know would be a
real boss mve if they got Aaron Taylor
Johnson back that would be sick I would
actually be very
excited who guys are entering all their
flashback that is cool
whoa help me I do like the bleeding of
reality in these
[Music]
bits get whoa get on the ground oh just
other
people damn a whole group it's like The
Walking Dead down here it's us or the
kaju this
way hey they're doing some cool shots
here with the lighting
though hey hey
hey go ahead without me yes we're going
together not at all yeah come on you can
do this we're a family maybe her lovers
still alive loving somebody else Only
Lovers Left Alive one of them goes
through no you don't know that you can't
know that we're going to die down here
another you sound just like Dad oh
what do you have to do that's more
important than us
oh I'll just go ahead and find a way
[Music]
out a poor woman I mean she's always on
the verge of tears but doesn't quite
ever get there it's a good metaphor for
this show breathe with me no I can't
there it is there it is yes you can come
onand come on
Randa bre out jaanese d one
more whoa I mean I find her pain the
most interesting because it's directly
correlated to the monsters it would be a
very real thing a lot of people would
experience got to get those minus ones
as many times as we
can hey whoa that's a different woman
you're living an enlightened life oh my
God she was having Affair you're just
like your father oh two
families or maybe she just has a healthy
and robust romantic life no I'll go it's
fine wow and she got a key to the H
heart dude that's why she was so blocked
off I didn't learn my lesson we were
good you just you don't want
good oh she sabotages I don't deserve
this that anyone would do for me
when all I ever do is let him down I
hear you how am I any better you didn't
let me down when I was freezing to death
in Alaska the only way out is through
true that I found a way out and it's
through just follow the
cats what do you know do you think Kate
had kids with that other woman
definitely and there's a whole other
side Monarch show happening where those
kids are looking for them right now
hey buddy this must have been a fun day
on set yeah but cats are going on strike
now yeah they want equal fair fair
animal actors don't want to be replaced
by CGI any longer what floor is it on
Dad loved a view the penthouse the
Pinnacle it's funny to have a show with
Kurt Russell on here when we're totally
beginning Escape From New York Vibes
references references for days
every movie is like a bunch of other
movies all of his offices look exactly
alike the pencil shavings he was messy
but he was a
scientist that's dangerous
what what
maybe should look the actual map
itself
yeah maybe one of is a photographic
memory the orbital arcs of satellites
are sine waves these
Pathways they're something else
oh these these points they're like
constellations but it's not a star map
star Maps it's a world map but he's
headd in the continent we got to get to
Alaska yes retrace our steps
they're migratory
patterns oh my God are we getting rares
of the Lost Arc moment let's
go oh
yeah and it makes a shape can you hold
that up over
there oh do an alignment thingy and use
the sun my first art installation was
about projected images that's convenient
how putting one image on another can
reveal something completely oh my God
yeah I remember they teach you that in
Japan dude your dad passed on all these
like yeah man genetic that's why he had
multiple families Choice making super
team at Monarch yeah with just all the
right
instincts H he got it wrong the first
time yeah give it a realistic touch oh
look out now San
Francisco Alaska oh Africa wow
Madagascar 3 we got to go to Africa all
around we got to go bring the window yes
and can we keep the Sun at this point in
the
sky thank God that's over tension relief
I Hest think didn't anyone get B out of
that get out of there I'm sorry for what
Dad did to you 30 years you wasted your
life on him no I encouraged this I had
many Affairs I wanted to be ply I could
have gone to Tokyo but I didn't want to
know the truth I liked having a
part-time husband but that meant that
that you had a part-time father and you
deserve more than that that is a Nuance
that's why she could not be full-time
lover d Part-Time Lover and a full-time
friend dad didn't die in Alaska he
worked for some secret organization like
the CIA but but for monsters for
Godzilla he worked for
Godzilla what was the onboarding like
has Godzilla right paychecks yeah what
kind of payroll does he established what
kind of currency is this based on it's a
Japanese needs money what if he loses
his temper in a
meeting I'm going to call my mom yes
remember the rule non specific yep get
the mom on the phone with with your
other Mom Mom I'm going to Africa see we
went to Japan for my race now we're
going to Africa for her race yes we're
going to find everybody's
ancestors yeah dude maybe maybe May has
a lost somebody yo who's she going to
call she's going to call Jack Reacher I
want to go home what what oh tell me
what I need to do what don't leave the
show and give all the info to Monarch
I'll be in touch dude it's been such a
big mystery about her home though like
where is she at this whole time like
where do she come from who are
[Music]
you I like you stoic
lady dude those scenes that Monarch were
crazy they were
like they were like oh there's so much
you don't know you're like y you don't
know what you really don't know and what
you want to know realize how much there
is not to know oh there's so much
knowing that you're just not believing
facts man they're hard to come by in
these parts all we got is Mystery I've
been really satisfied with five episodes
of that definitely definitely it's five
episodes of like man my dad was real
tough but why' he do this to us we got
to find him though okay
yeah but man he was tough but we got to
find
him yeah he kind of traumatized us but
we gotta find
out yo cap just be dropping truth bombs
to her mom like nobody's business I know
well we can't afford to you know unpack
this we got to get out there and
freaking quarantine Zone it up so when I
go show up to see my mom after all this
time yo dad had an affair
that's that's the sun over there yeah
Hey listen why aren't you reacting the
way I would expect you to
react why aren't you taking this more
gracefully slash also unpack this with
me right now all right day two all right
now that I'm back here in the morning
after you've pulled an all nighter
dad he uh worked for the secret
organization of people who they work for
Godzilla they worked for
Godzilla
yeah man damn compelling drama don't be
stopping but um in terms of character
drama I think um whoever plays Kate I
think she is the best she's been so
far
agree a there good ways of
saying espe she been so far this episode
gave her some stuff to to work with I I
was here just going like I would have
rather watched her pointless prequel
show show that took place during the
events of Godzilla sure where we could
actually feel like we're not being
teased with an old
movie like it was in it's like the
flashbacks even though they're
flashbacks I thought the flashbacks were
more compelling and intense I'm talking
about even the moments where you don't
see Godzilla like that that alone was
just so immediate and then then having
to handle the the relationship drama in
the midst of knowing that of of the
impending doom that where are they San
Francisco yes yeah knowing what the the
impending doom of San Francisco is
before them and then also the
na
of n the Nativity Story the nativity
scene yeah of of of like oh we're at
school and they're like yeah it might be
fake like I like the the the Nuance of
that of of her seeing the
phone I I thought about that too I was
like oh you know what if they were like
ah there's a monster attack and someone
showed me footage on on YouTube I'd be
like really good that look great living
made this did a good job yeah that look
but I totally wouldn't believe it either
yeah but if there in San for there be
like rumbles happening well there would
be too much I feel like military and I'm
sure somebody would be able to and the
further away you are sure but I feel
like people kid at school today if you
if you were if you I'll give the benefit
I'll give a massive benefit of the doubt
to people who might have been out of
town but if you were anywhere near San
Francisco at the time how could you have
any reservation about the the the thing
that like caused all this you know
seismic activity destruction loud you
know sirens and explosions and popping
and crushing and all this stuff well you
see okay they they they' mentioned minus
one here a couple of times and I'm going
to tell you why minus one is a very
interesting character drama of why it
still works even though Godzilla is like
only in the movie for like 20 minutes in
that film without spoiling it okay is
that the character's
traumatic memory is linked to an
encounter with Godzilla
yes and everything we were watching
after it it do you know anything about
minus one not really you know anything I
don't know
I didn't know anything about it either
good I've only heard people describe
what they love about it which are have
not been in any anything about the plot
I don't know anything about how the
movie presents itself I just know that
it has very endearing and Rich uh human
characters okay then I'm I won't go too
far into it because I I didn't know any
I was I didn't even know when it took
place and all that so I was like watch
yeah I don't know anything that
yeah somehow at the moment I know almost
nothing about it other than everyone's
like this could win an Oscar if they
wanted it to you know it's pretty great
and it was made for $15 million
apparently yeah yeah so that that's just
one element of why okay I'd have to
elaborate a little bit more to really
sounds like the traumatic flashbacks are
very vital to the telling of that story
but even if even when they're not
focused on Godzilla and they're focused
on like other stuff yeah there's still
some type of connection where
the the shadow that Godzilla casts yeah
yeah the Paul PA for yeah yeah you love
that word but I just think of Paul from
heavy spoiler so I don't use that of p p
a l l i know what the word is if it if
like a h casting a dark shadow over
things that's why I said that bloming P
yeah but anyway I mean yeah it's like
I'm being kind of for anyone who's seen
the movie is like that's I would I would
go little for like yeah I'm potentially
holding back preserving my Virgin years
yeah
um how and and so I think with Kate
that's part of what like what makes her
a little interesting is her her
[Music]
um her even though like there a lot okay
this thing with her lover and cheating
and all that and her
dad I don't know it's it's more
interesting than it was before is what I
could say it is it was more interesting
than it was before I want nice today
John I know I want be nice I'll be the
kudin thece I mean no I there was cool
shots that reminded me of The Last of Us
in the world and uh Kurt Russell's
charming and yes and I liked him he's a
good actor he's a good actor and the the
deputy lady I like her too and I like
this stoic action Kobe smolders lady I
like Karo just the first time in America
first time being around a bunch of like
destruction and rubble and he's just so
casual cool be chilling yeah feing his
funions or yeah man I I thought it felt
like there was a scene deleted somewhere
there I mean it was nice I like I like
the mom casting the moms continue to
kill it how to show whoever cast this
show has a good relationship with their
mom yeah whoever writes these scripts
seems to have a good relationship with
their mom just because the moms are
inevitably the most the the kentaro's
mom is a better character than uh Kate's
mom just cuz we've SP more time with her
but they're both the characters of the
most heart so far they're different I
know different they're different
characters I'm not saying they're not I
I agree Kar Kate's mom has dealt with
gday yeah and she's like continuing to
whereas kentaro's mom is like kind of
completely as we understand sort of
separated from all that stuff yeah and
yeah no I iar's mom seems like she kind
of knew
sure yeah well and deep down you know
know Kate's mom certainly didn't uh try
too hard to confirm or deny her
suspicions which means deep down she she
knew yeah totally so uh I I appreciate
those things I thought this was a decent
episode like getting uh you know these
little glimpses and stuff like that
little Flesh on the character bones all
that is nice uh you know I I keep
on you said something during one of
those scenes about like always
well then I'm going to resay it and take
credit for saying it uh that like uh the
lead is always kind of on the verge of
tears but never quite crying and I feel
like that's how this show operates in
terms of character development I'm
always like oh we're introducing
something that could be an interesting
nuanced thread that we could just spend
a moment having you know play out and we
and we we got kind of close to some of
those things I think the the sweetest
moment is when kintaro is trying to
cheer her up and they're singing this
silly little song together
even though that kind of clashes with
the circumstances but I'll let it slide
uh there's a lot of lamp shading of
those things that's fine uh I think they
want to be the last of us but they they
pacing wise they can't do
it I don't cuz there is kind there is
like a somber melancholic thing that I
think they want to do but you want to
look up at those buildings and have that
like whoa like that sort of breathtaking
existential that happens when you see
like a man-made structure you know
ruined by nature or or completely
reclaimed by Nature well I saw this
these quote this quote going I think it
was from Matt shackman and if something
about uh what gets what we get people to
return every week is is the characters
not the
monsters it's a bit of both it's called
Monarch Legacy of monsters by the way so
you know I kind of show for some
monsters but whatever um just having the
characters on screen is what people show
up for I guess by that by that uh metric
yeah cuz the characters certainly were
on screen a lot during this episode but
this feels like it is written by I'm so
baffled that it's Matt shackman partly
helping to to shepher this just because
this does feel like it is written by
people who are uh divorced from the idea
that the plot is not the story uh
necessarily so like I I always feel when
I'm watching this like okay this is like
a 100% Plot show and any piece of
character intimacy we
get barring a couple is like for
functionality and for the plot like I
liked they I know maybe John maybe I
liked that we got a glimpse into Kate's
life that's your opinion I always just
feel like we're scratching the surface
of these things and I'm not again it's
weird it's weird to be in the I don't
know how to how to quite articulate this
position cuz I'm not sitting here going
I want lifechanging drama out of this I
just want to feel like there's like
character beats where like somebody
brought a little bit of their own life
experience and and like everything is
very boilerplate continually so it's
like oh oh here's her tragic backstory
she had a
love and that loves a woman and uh
because her dad is bad at family
she's bad at commitment and I'm like
cool that's a good beat that's a good
character Nuance that's something that
real people embody however I really feel
like I just experienced only those
bullet points and an actual I don't know
like when scenes play out the way
they're written here it kind of starts
to dismantle all the other movie Magic
that goes into it because then I just
feel like I'm watching Pretty actors on
a pretty set well it's not I I think
what you're trying to say your opinion
not mine yes is uh I am alone you you're
very much that chosen I hope you know
that sure none of this I think what
you're trying to say is that it's not
really about hey I want to spend like
more time in these scenes you just want
the again God like a movie like Godzilla
minus one is two hours okay this we've
been here for five
yeah this so felt like two hours and and
my point is is that the common rhetoric
with that movie is people connect with
the characters and it can be done and
it's not about oh because they gave me
five hours with the characters yeah it's
just about how you execute the
particular scenes where the emotion is
there or the combination of performer
and qualitative writing in the of what's
and direct ction in the moment there's a
lot that goes into communicating and
emotion which is editing your music
choice the
atmosphere the performance the dialogue
there's a lot that it's not about like I
want to see more of this affair it's
just about like the it's how you
articulate it it's it's how yeah those
certain scenes go down that should evoke
an emotion in you is what I think you're
trying to say I completely feel all
those things yeah I don't know I'm on
the I'm on I'm halfway to tears every
time it feels like it just they they
deliver they keep delivering information
rather than like letting anything like
breathe in itself why you feel that way
not me well yeah yeah yeah and and my my
personal opinion is that uh it's like if
you're GNA go woke embrace it bro no
like uh I don't know like it's nice that
they made her you know uh uh a queer
character but it also feels it's weird
it doesn't feel necessarily quite as
Shameless as as I'm sure somebody will
say like it's pandering like they spend
enough time and it's like hard enough to
cut down for some foreign market that
doesn't approve of that that it feels
like they committed to the choice
however it also uh doesn't feel like it
serves much of a purpose which I guess
is cool I guess you want it to be such
that like oh these characters are gay
and and the issues they're dealing with
are Universal still she can't commit
because of her dad and she's sabotaging
this situation with her uh I guess
girlfriend or or her potential Lover by
you know sleeping around and like all
that is fine like you can again you
don't have to create like the most
unfathomable circumstances to to make me
endeared to your character you just got
to treat it like it's not requisite
information delivery I guess that's how
it always feels to me uh so you know
it's like I always feel the actors I
feel bad cuz I always feel the
actors carrying all the way to the
script like the script weighs so much
down on this
show for me I think chemist I think
chemistry is very important and I think
what you're trying to say too is you
don't feel like a real sense of
chemistry with our main cast of
characters not really and I don't know
that's your opinion what to attribute
that to yeah yeah no don't put I won't
put words in your mouth
it's well I like all the cast
individually yeah and there's something
about I feel I can feel the potential
that these actors would potentially have
chemistry and at the same time I don't
feel like the direction is like bad but
I also don't think the direction is
particularly attuned to character stuff
either so like the the most effective
things are yeah when you're like in the
quarantine Zone and and you got like The
Vibes to ride in on but it's like if you
want this to be your last of us episode
three you know you you I don't like it's
weird they they have this whole motif of
her PTSD which is such an interesting
thing to do here and I feel like it is
simply just an excuse to have Godzilla
footage sometimes it feels
like and again this is just what I
imagine you're trying to say yes me is
that yeah please help me yeah is that
sometimes it feels
like actors with potential who are
figuring out these scenes in an acting
class kind of it feels like we're
watching rehearsals before they actually
found the right camera angles and like
the right approach to the scene like
every scene feels like we're watching
rehearsal and we're watching them test
out a camera angle and it's so strange
like I it's a fascinating con because
the monsterverse movies have always been
up and down in how they handle human
characters but I feel like the movie
that they're hearkening back to the most
the 2014 one has arguably the most
tempered grip on that John we don't need
to repeat ourselves over and over again
especially yourself I know I I am alone
in this and I just keep on H I think
like especially after watching and I
felt this way with the other movies
after every movie after Godzilla 2014 I
felt this way is that sure the
characters suck but whenever they get to
I don't I do like Gia and Alexander I do
like the little I don't know the
actress's name I do like Gia and I like
Alexander scar scar
yeah do like that um anyway that MEK at
least made the characters palatable but
my point is that whenever they actually
get to the monster stuff though they
give so much TLC to that yeah not just
in like visual effects but like there is
an emotion and it is genuinely like
exciting and fun and cool and you're at
least like ah well at least at least I
know why I'm here and they a rush to get
to here and this show is not about the
monsters this show is about its
characters and its mystery box and it's
and it's like but its characters and uh
is are just not as um it feels like it's
about its characters but written by
somebody who is being forced to write
about these characters and doesn't
actually want
to I don't know I can't tell what they
want cuz it doesn't seem like they're
struggling to bring in Ka I know I'm
sorry Legacy of Monsters the monsters
are are demons in our past or something
what they're say and Monarch is bad but
maybe not all badarch Legacy of our of
our past consequences and choices some
grinding cliche yeah
and just so much of what is happening is
just like I it's supposed to go hand in
hand yeah it's a post I think that's the
thing is like you want like I'm not big
on the shoulds and shouldn'ts have right
I'm really not big on that it's I I am
thinking though why it's not as
effective and it's
because they normally that's why I keep
comparing it to minus one with the vager
I'm doing because I don't want to spoil
anything for John is that um you you you
need it to go there needs to be a like a
link between yeah
the there needs to be an interplay
between like the adventure circumstances
and the character grow yeah like as
they're facing so Kate's the closest
you'll get yeah but you know like canaro
a dedicated episode to
uncovering his art history here the
point of that episode is why is Sam here
has nothing to do with or may sorry May
Sam May why is has nothing to do with
Kaiju or godilla or any of that
like it needs to go hand because it
feels like they're completely separate
things like one is like a okay yeah this
person can have a
backstory but once it becomes like the
focus yeah of something like well this
feels so divorced and and not in in um
in correlation or they don't feel
complimentary feel they're shaping each
other like there should be a back and
forth of like this journey I'm trying to
be nice the more they the more they
discover about their dad's alternate
life the more it should sort of alter
and Enlighten their growth along the way
and I feel like yeah or it should lead
to something about Monarch even if it's
not about Kaiju it should be something
with the
plot the plot and character development
have to go hand inand and the character
development just seems like such a
separate thing it feels yeah completely
divorced and like a thing we do when we
have time for it or when we need to
create some kind of tension like it's so
weird loved that they went into the
quarantine Zone and I thought they could
have made that more tense and the most
tension you get is when she's having the
panic attacks stupid soldiers and then
and got these dumb soldiers evade it
like a video game maneuver and it's just
this one little cluster of them and then
yeah and then you follow the cat like
yeah I just it it's uh it's it's
interesting the the way that they seem
to just keep this cycle going of like
we're just got to keep going around the
world to find Dad we got to find Dad and
and everywhere we go there's some more
information about what dad knows about
this stuff but but it never feels like
we're getting little rewards of
information along the way and and people
just keep again it feels like a JJ
Abrams Mystery Box where people keep on
talking up like oh man oh man our our
deep dark secrets we can't get him out
there and you know stuff that we don't
know and you're dad and I'm like is
there anything in the box but lost at
least had like a something that felt
like s it the feeling was so compound
telling though that you had to tune in
every week because you're like I don't
know if I learned anything but I
certainly got more questions still feel
yeah I got more question even if you
didn't get answers you got more
questions and here I'm just like I got
the same questions and and and lost
would at least throw you like a weird
detail or something disconcerting or it
would get quirky or or yeah there was
always this tone of sort of dread and
and mystery and like something's lurking
that you can't Define and and we're
talking about a universe where like
there's way more giant monsters and and
strange tyy wiy things that are
happening that we don't all even know
about and yet I don't know it doesn't
feel like there are that many of these
creatures roving around at the moment
and yeah and there's also like weird
planetary travel stuff that you can do
yeah like in God still versus Kong they
go to
Alaska to get Kong into Hollow
Earth right was in Alaska you your
rewatch is more recent than mine it's
one it's like an icy Place definitely
wasn't Hong Kong yeah and then and then
and then when um Godzilla and then when
Kong gets to his
chair and then Godzilla attacks he looks
through the hole he's in Hong Kong and I
don't think Alaska and Hong Kong are
like that close to each other right so
my point is is like that there's
something with Hollow Earth that creates
an interesting thing about travel yeah
yeah yeah and I thought like oh we might
do something like that here um but then
again no one's ever been to Hollow Earth
supposedly but
maybe Russell has maybe that's why he's
90 but he's not actually he's more like
70 20 years behind his aging
um yes characters uh they just lack
compellingness but you know well it's
getting better it's getting it's it's
it's just yeah it's getting all it keeps
getting all right and it maintains ains
an okayness I think it is suffering the
one thing I will concretely say is that
I do think that It suffers in these last
two episodes from not having any of the
1950 stuff and what oh no no no the
modern day characters in their chry I
don't want to be the guy who gets hung
up on what I want rather than what
they're trying to do but I did feel like
having the contrast back and forth in
these two simultaneous stories was an
interesting hook and was so an actual
mystery there
yeah I felt like I'm also learning stuff
and my I'm getting more questions than
when a question gets answered it's
pretty and here it's
just whoa dad had his map yeah whoa hey
he didn't have a safe but he
did he put these bullet points for us
to put up on the the sunrise at the
window and and
uh this is a strange very strange show
it's very
odd it's like if we look I think last
episode is more of a prime example of it
all like sure how does canaro facing his
past traumas lead to him getting on that
helicopter and
saving um everyone right like he just he
just faces it and then cut to he's on a
helicopter out of nowhere as opposed to
like show it didn't help with some it
didn't help with something like
overcoming something yeah you know like
there's no real growth he just okay he
faced it but then that's this a totally
different situation I mean by how it's
divorced and it's kind of the same thing
here like she's running like like she's
forced to kind of run through the town
but it's not like hey hey we need to
keep going I can't I can't keep going no
no we have to keep going it's like and
she's like getting paralyzed because
she's struck by her own trauma and it's
like okay in order for them to get the
necessary thing she has to overcome her
trauma yeah you know and like why is
Kate the one essential why can't why
can't uh may may may why can't May and
canaro just go and and do it themselves
uh because they're not the main
character I guess but it's they're like
but why why can't can like what that
should be addressed like why we need
Kate to go but but Kate is too AF like
all he have to do is like a little bit
of reworking is like
Kate has to be the one for some reason I
don't know show you're the ones with the
writers you make it up because they're
both genetically inheriting their
fathers blah blah blah but I'm saying
like there's a plot-wise plot just plot
not even character wise like why Kate
has to be the one to go yes right why
they need her there she okay there you
go she's the one who knows San Francisco
she's the one who knows how to navigate
right that's what the show say that's
what they do right so they they need her
yeah they need her but Kate's like I
can't I can't go through I can't go
through there again I can't it's it's
too hard for me she she has to deal with
all the trauma yeah and then and
then so every single time there's a
hurdle or something or there're getting
fear then they have to like Po like in
order for them to complete the mission
Kate has to face her trauma to start
clearing trauma and I think that's what
they were
doing but it's not clear it just kind of
seems like they did some of that but
imagine if that's what we all were in
unison on imagine if it wasn't just oh
she has to face her trauma now every
single time we're getting a flashback it
feels like essential because then she
gets her big crying moment that she got
here and you're like okay now we can
proceed forward know where we have to go
let's do this and then she leads the
charge yeah it shouldn't just be the
thing we do while canaro finds the way
out off screen yeah and now it's like
May yeah and then and then may is now
like I want to go home and so like when
when deputy director lady or whatever I
don't know what her position is when she
said um they're like oh but this one's
interest when one tough girl uh assassin
woman says uh oh this one's interesting
about May and she and then deputy
director related it's like you don't
even know like what I bet you guys don't
even know what what their positions are
but I say that you just know what
who the I'm talking about totally
well cuz only four people work at
Monarch right now so then deputy
director lady is like but what what is
her backstory why did I was hearing just
going what the does it matter this
the most random character of all of them
like what does it what does it matter
what what her backstory is or what she
does like what do you care she DEC the
files that's all your concern
is and like it's and it's so strange
because it's like they could make
something out of her because she's just
she has been along for the ride and I
like this the idea and the work in the
scene of her consoling Kate but at the
same time they've not really done
anything to really buy or sell the idea
that like she is opening up as a person
to like it seems like she just doing
this cuz it's like a good thing to do
you don't want to be a jerk in a
situation and leave somebody FL in as
they're going through trauma but she's
sarcastic yeah so she's likable yep
totes she's like give her give her dry
sarcasm to mask her pain it was nice
getting now we got a Carr it was nice
getting to that point where they were
singing and they were doing this stuff
later on in the episode because I was
starting to get a little bit graded on
about the in the first half I started to
find it a bit grading that I'm like I
know that all these three of the main
characters
are they're dealing with trauma and
they're dealing with pasts and all that
stuff this is a grumpy gang to hang out
with and they're always kind of snippy
at each other and and I'm not I'm not
like having fun watching them despite
that or I'm not like well you know but
they've got like an appealing attitude
they just all seem tired and annoyed
it's CU their lack of chemistry yeah I
guess so I guess that is what it is like
to use a very different Dynamic of a
bunch of traumatized characters who
would like messed up sto Back stories
but then and when they hang out they
don't get along but they have chemistry
and The Breakfast Club yeah The
Breakfast Club man that's what we knew
was little Godzilla Breakfast Club just
herting the kids Godzilla attacks
Guardians of the Galaxy The Suicide
Squad anything of something of like we
don't belong together but actors have
chemistry so we like watching them not
get along yeah cuz you know underneath
that so so then well you know the reason
they don't get along is because of some
actual thing underneath that'll come out
it could be as simple as like a cop from
Hong Kong and an LA cop have to work
together to save a save a little girl
neither of them wants a partner but
they're forced to work the case yeah but
you're like oh man but if you guys were
able to move past this you could be
unstoppable you guys could be yeah you
could have a whole
franchise then they had this whole thing
with Tim being like monarchs in blood I
was like ah is is that where we we were
going with this this whole time is I
think they are genetically
predisposed to have like his intellect
and be able to figure his out like
I think they mean that when they say
Monarch is think they're going to do
some like weird sci-fi mumbo jumbo I do
I think they are chosen I think whatever
Juju permeated Le I don't know man I
think it was more like how what's his
name who's there who's Let Them Fight
was everyone in the room for that
apparently K Russ was yeah uh
uh senzawa s sarawa there you go swa's
kids in Godzilla versus Kong he's the
one who pilot sh uh not Shin Godzilla
Mecha Godzilla mea Godzilla okay oh
that's right damn yeah so I think that's
what they mean by family I guess
so I I I think it's going to be some
kind of J I think I think this this
team's we're going to see in Godzilla
EXO
I sure hope finally going to get the
team of mod characters up waiting well
the thing is about that though I mean
like with these movies interesting if I
knew that's where they were going with
these well I mean the thing about these
American Godzilla Productions is that
part of you especially with the track
record they've established part of me
I'm like well I might not be loving
these characters as of this part of the
franchise but if they come back in a
different part under a slightly
different
guiding voice it could work you know
started off strong this show yeah it did
I've been seeing the audience score
dipping too and I'm like thank God
people have been catching up with us
yeah well because it starts with so much
promise still Prett but it stagnates I
well just yeah I don't know it starts
out with that promise at the beginning
and you're like cool I can look past
whatever else because I'm sure once we
get into the meat we're going to flesh
all that out and I'm like we're halfway
into a 10 episode season and I'm like I
feel like we've done so much like
physical wheel spinning for like very
little actual progress your characters
aren't interesting enough for me to
not to for me to like disregard the lack
of monster fun yeah and I'm and I will
be the first person happy to do that
which is with godzill Al Mighty does so
well is you'll feel like like you won't
forget it's a Godzilla movie but you're
not like but you're not thinking about
that so that when it comes in you're
like oh that's right like yeah totally
yeah yeah yeah
there there's another I won't mention
there's another movie recently that gave
me that exact thing where I was like
there's stuff I expect from things like
this but I'm not even thinking about
that and that's one of the best
surprises possible sawx yeah actually
there are like saw elements to that
movie that like it doesn't forget about
but I forgot about while I was just
being pulled into the movie and I love
when that happens I would love to be
Bamboozled by characters I actually care
for and then get some Kaiju icing on top
sorry man I got to watch watch
um I got to watch the first Purge and um
now you see me too so I can make sure
adits are good we've not said enough
about this we'll get to the bottom of it
in another hour or
so this is why we were up late yeah just
because we don't know how to shut up
we're fil and for some reason this show
always inspires the most like long
winded like why doesn't this work it
shouldn't be that hard it was just like
if if if people just straightforwardly
dislike the show it would be so much
talk about cuz each time yeah every time
an episode finishes you're like what is
it that I don't see in this that
everybody else seems to like
losing their over I don't think I'm
asking too much I don't think I'm being
too much of a grump about this I just
wish that it felt like we were moving
anywhere yeah Kurt Russell I feel like
we've spent way more time with Wyatt
Russell than Kurt Russell and I mean I
just I just feel like you know like when
people when people say the two I
don't know Kurt Russell's just kind of
Kurt Russell's Charming but I don't
really coed man I don't really give a
about they're not using him
yeah which is fine if we have Wyatt
Russell but we don't now the um it's I I
I don't know exactly what people would
say when you're like well it's not fair
to compare Godzilla minus one and this
like I could see a variety of reasons
why people would say that but I I'll
boil it down to what just doesn't what
baffles me is what is the two-hour movie
where there's at least like 20 minutes
of of like intense
action so really it's like an hour and a
half of character moments there sure and
it's a 90-minute movie with a 20 minute
Kaiju scene kind of to oversimplify sure
I don't yeah it's more spread out than
that yeah um it I'm saying that we're
here we've been here for freaking
um five hours this they these guys
should be more interesting yeah and
there bottom line they should they just
should be like I should care more about
what I'm watching but when the three of
them are like at the airport and I'm
watching this like forc interactions
like oh I'm angry at the flight
attendant lady I'm like there's
something that just feels so off about
the direction this is just kind of
abrasive yeah I don't know I feel like
there's they're like one camera shot
away from being like a Neil brenen fil
like like one shot away maybe
yeah of of getting good actors and just
making them Capt capturing them in a an
off off way because there's no chemistry
and it's it's really it's really rough
it's rough it is rough it's it's so
strange I'm trying I was really trying
John and you broke me broke me down it's
okay this is the one broke me down John
I was I was so good I I was like oh
10 minutes in I'm God I said all nice
things I'm ready to recall this video
These no and you wanted to keep talking
second half of the Season get ready
right it's going to be so good kept
talking and now here I am back to the
dark side next episode is going to be
great it's going to give us some
Revelations we're going to feel like I
can't wait man this Monarch feels so
these three people and one of whom is a
good hacker and the other two are just
as ones they're just regular people
pretty much have like this whole shadowy
Monarch agency like what do we do about
these
three and I'm like why though like I get
that may is a good hacker but other than
that why why do he cuz it's randos yeah
he randos kids there's nothing we can do
to contain them we just got to let them
do their thing and follow
along oh it's like they didn't know
about any of this until like a few
days ago yeah and they're just like
finding random scraps their dad left
around that are CA like they're CA
requiring so much like Globe trotting
and like crazy like there there's just
so many like easier ways to simplify
intensity here of just I think I think
they get lost in the weeds of
pretentious exploration of of just just
go down you got someone at Monarch who's
like just kill them and then other
people are like we shouldn't kill them
because these are randa's kids yeah and
then that's the Divide about Legacy of
like does it matter that it's randa's
cuz yes Randa John Goodman is like the
start of Monarch and so should should
they should they be kept alive just
because of that what does monarch do I
mean I thought we're the good people now
we're just going to kill them off
because they know too much and are they
maybe like irradiated with some kind of
Kaiju guju you de construct you need to
study yeah you do have with Kur
Russell's character you get the Sci-Fi
element of like why instead of just
constantly being like shouldn't you be
90 like you get you get like a they just
keep lamp shading all the Mysteries and
then stretching them out it's like
there's way
where you could do what you're doing and
just make it so much more compelling of
just like you have a debate about the
ethics of Monarch and what Monarch's
places in this world and what Monarch
does and then you get the Sci-Fi Juju
with Kurt Russell and then bam you got
two sides of Monarch which are
interesting yeah and then you get the
backstory in the 50s let let's you see
the monsters yeah well we still
have yet to see where Kurt Russell in
Wyatt Russell form learns you know all
the stuff that he keeps saying to them
about like ah you guys aren't really in
control you don't really know what
you're dealing with you didn't listen to
me you know and I'm like I would love to
go back to that and listen to that yeah
no it's it's it's really uh yeah I feel
like it's just being really dragged out
it's it kind of feels like I'm watching
Iron Fist looks yeah it feels like
somebody like it feels like a drink
somebody realized they needed to get 10
people a drink and they only had a
pitcher for three glasses so they're
just like just dump more water into this
and sprad it out this was five episodes
how much more interesting like there was
stuff here like there should have been
episode two there was stuff here I was
watching like five and we got our lead a
bit of backstory yeah I was like yeah
this should have I should have learned
this would have been great in like
episode there's so much I was watching
like this would have been so good to see
it and how much are we going to actually
touch back on this because my fear also
is that we're going to have like oh man
rainbow flags and and it's got her
girlfriend oh she's she's living this
double life she's cheating and whatnot
and then I feel like we're almost never
going to touch on her romantic life ever
again after this point I mean I I like
kind of the casualness of her just being
gay but then the show does like
production design choices that seem to
be like gay they meet at the activism
coffee shop look how G and school that
they go to has R is a rainbow school day
and I'm like I know San Francisco was
one of the first PE places in America to
legalize gay marriage as as a a thrive
gay community but I I don't know it
didn't feel like it was lovingly handled
here it felt like it did have that
Pander version it felt like a Capital C
Choice yeah and it didn't feel like it's
yeah it's the problem it empowers people
who feel like they are Cartman in the
Pander verse episode because it is like
I am happy that you did this and since
this is a madeup character it doesn't
matter so people don't need to be mad
even though I'm sure they will but what
is like I'd rather have the choice then
not have the choice but also like did
you really care when you made the choice
or did you just is it another arbitrary
have better if you just kept the
relationship instead of trying to be
like gay stuff oh and cuz it was off
like I I could give a sh I didn't even
like notice the flag like I didn't you
were pointing it out and but the thing
is like a lot of people will notice it
like I didn't even notice any of that
stuff I was more like oh thank God back
story yes yeah maybe we all get to know
this character a bit better and feel her
struggle a little bit more she has
emotional things that are not worse Papa
and I was I was connected to that so and
I lik how they like made her a cheater
like oh that's a little interesting so
she's got flaws without being a a
stereotypical crazy Hollywood lesbian
character yeah and it would have been
more cliche if it was like a guy cuz
then it's like oh here's her daddy is
shoes so I'm like yeah make her gay
that's cool um but there and again it's
always about how some is captured and
and so once you start like showing like
a bunch of like hey iconography all
stuff I feel like like and now I feel
like is the show trying to make this
feel lived in or are they forcing are we
going heightened are we going Liv I I
can't tell now now now I'm distracted by
it because the show's drawing attention
to it when before if it was just like
they show up they kiss and they're in a
relationship I wouldn't even thought
twice about it well and it doesn't and
then the trouble then for me becomes too
that two of them are so utterly perfect
that it breaks the illusion that much
further because like her girlfriend I
again fine actress I like the presence
of that character uh but I don't feel
like they're I don't know just it it
felt like actors on a set who are put
together CU they're both attractive
rather than like a real relationship
yeah you know and it's like give those
like I'm sure both of those actors are
capable of making that feel lived in
without a whole lot of excess oh totally
John you know over rot effort look man
we gota end this we got we're done get
up early this is the longest video of
the Year guys what you think of Monarch
episode five uh leave your thoughts down
below I think we'll finish it we'll let
you know it's going to be good rage
watch along with us sure yeah do
whatever you want if you're still here
you you've made your
bet you know what you're getting into
it's only uphill from here I've been
trying to be nice next week episode 6 is
going to be good it's going to be the
best one yet all right I'll see you guys
soon bye everyone bye bye John bye
[Music]
Greg